argentina colombia y bolivia se suman a
la lista de más de 25 países fuera de la
unión europea que deben hacer cuarentena
obligatoria al entrar a españa no
importa el aeropuerto al cual aterricen
y si ha habido o no escalas
intermediarias la medida fue publicada
por el boletín oficial del estado este
sábado 24 de julio y exige que los
viajeros de estos destinos guarden 10
días de aislamiento sólo podrán salir
antes y al séptimo día presentan una
prueba negativa válida en el país
europeo la nación ibérica continúa
pasando por una ola de kobe 19 desde
hace semanas cifras oficiales señalan
que a principio de julio los casos
pasaban los 6000 y a la fecha superan
los 25 mil en colombia pese a que han
disminuido los contagios el presidente
iván duque confirmó con preocupación la
llegada al país de la variante delta
es preciso indicar que el instituto
nacional de salud ha identificado la
presencia de la variante delta en
nuestro país en un caso que fue sometido
a examen en la ciudad de cali y que ya
ha sido tratado obviamente con todos los
protocolos médicos argentina colombia y
bolivia avanzan en la vacunación de la
población sin embargo la situación
epidemiológica de estas naciones sigue
siendo catalogada de alto riesgo porque
se encuentran en una ola de contagios de
coronavirus desde hace meses